it is time to answer your questions we
have questions from any number of
different internet sources today first
is from ask the alligator I believe on
YouTube Twitter Twitter asked the
alligator on Twitter can you find I'm
guessing this is being asked to us as
heterosexual males can you find a woman
attractive if she is an idiot for
example Sarah Palin attractive but
repulsive in personality for me
personality is quite important Lois
so I don't know you know I think
everybody will have a slightly different
answer many people are probably willing
to tolerate more idiocy or ignorant
if the attractiveness is also higher to
some extent I don't know there's
probably sort of a scale right yeah
maybe
a long time ago it used to be this is
important to people now back in the day
it used to be more women used to be more
what's the word desirable if they were
dumb the dumb ditzy blind Marilyn Monroe
used to pretend to be an idiot even
though she wasn't an idiot right
and that was desirable and now that has
turned around now it's it's it's
attractive to be intelligent let me make
a caveat okay I think in coastal liberal
cultures what you're saying is true my
recent interactions when I've been in
other parts of the country were the
paradigm of the Northeast and the coasts
the west coast and big cities have not
been in play is that there seems to be
and I'm generalizing here and I know
that there are exceptions to this there
still seems to be more of both desire
and acceptance of the sort of bystander
less opinionated less informed and
engaged woman partner to the
heterosexual male and we're really
talking about at the the sort of
male-female relationship here and of
course that's not the type of
relationship everybody is in I think
things have changed more in this part of
the country Louis then and maybe some
others that that could be I did notice
during my my brief stint on on
online dating which just infuriated me
to no end but people now will put that
there sapiosexual okay
which means that they find intelligence
sexy Wow yeah they're attracted to that
and while this may be true I think that
this really only means you find that
appealing only after said person has
passed through physical requirements so
what you're saying is that there's some
initial physical attractiveness level
that sort of has to be met before
intelligence differences would have a
significant impact on overall
attractiveness and understanding yeah
what about in situations where you get
to know someone more extensively before
you're aware of their physical
appearance could it be that you are more
open to developing a relationship in
which you were attractive your
attractiveness rather you're being
attracted to the person is more based on
intelligence and personality and then
you are exposed to their physical
attractiveness is it possible that it
would have less of an impact still
probably some sort of minimum level that
that would have to be met for you to be
overall attracted but could that sort of
change up the paradigm it could that
could happen I'm sure that does happen
but that is an exception to the rule
okay in my opinion Sarah Palin I mean it
would balance it out does her wretched
personality ignorance and personal views
completely outweigh any physical
attraction you might feel towards her
yes but I did not feel a strong physical
attraction to her to begin okay yeah
yeah I mean it you know Sarah Palin it
would be hard to even have a two-minute
conversation with her in anything other
than like some kind of interview setting
or something like that I don't know well
you could probably talk about things
non-political and maybe she'd have some
great insight you know Ella cars
shooting caribou yeah